Evan wrote in, Evan says, Hey David, when
do you think Tulsi is going to take Elizabeth
Warren down?
Listen, it's not gonna happen.
Okay.
And I, the, the conversation we've talked
enough about Tulsi Gabbert and other candidates
that have these sort of cults of personality
around them.
I don't even really listen.
If you, if you literally believe that at some
point in the future in the 2020 primary, you
will look at the polls and Tulsi Gabard will
be ahead of Elizabeth Warren.
I probably can't talk you out of that belief.
You're probably ideologically committed to
that belief regardless of what the facts are
about the way that this primary is going.
So I don't even want to argue about that.
What I want to think about is when the Tulsi
people or the yang people, cause I, I hear
this from both the Tulsi people in the yang
people.
This is an honest question for you guys.
When you write into me and you say, David,
the poles, I don't care what they say soon
Andrew Yang will be in the lead or soon Tulsi
Gabard will be in the lead.
Do you literally believe that or is it something
you say to keep up the momentum and the energy
and to try to energize the supporters?
I genuinely want to know the answer to that
because if people really literally are sitting
around saying, I don't care that Tulsi Gavin's
pulling 0.8% any day, now all of a sudden
she's going to surge.
Whether it was her threat to boy, her pre
debate threat to boycott the debate or whether
it's her performance in a debate or whatever.
What is it that you believe is going to happen
in the minds of the American people that they
will see her and say, you know what, I, I
now realize I have to support Tulsi Gabbert.
What are, what are the mechanics that you
think are going to lead to that?
And if it's just something that you're saying
in order to keep people energized or keep
the energy up, I, that's fine.
I would actually respect you much more if
you wrote to me and you said, you know what
David, I do go around online posting on YouTube
videos including yours or those of others.
Tulsi is eventually going to take over.
Yang is eventually going to take over the
lead.
I don't actually believe it.
I'm just being positive.
I would respect that sincerely.
Uh, but if you are actually waiting around
for the day that you believe is coming where
they will be in the lead of the democratic
primary, I want to figure out exactly what
it is that you're thinking.
And I do think that this relates to the very
counterproductive cults of personality, personality
around some of these candidates that I don't
really get what the end game is.
And I know that eventually when these candidates
don't win and drop out or just lose a, you
will then come forward and have some other
kind of motivated reasoning to explain who
screwed them or what conspiracy led to them
not winning, even though they otherwise would
have.
And it'll be a, you know, endless, endless,
motivated reasoning along those lines.
I want some of you to get in touch and say,
you know what, David, I don't believe that
they're going to win.
It's just something I go around saying because
it either makes me feel good or it makes other
people feel good.
I'd respect you for telling me that